it was from here his rural Massachusetts
home the Jack Tashira blew a hole in U.S
national security
having started out transcribing
classified material and then posting it
online he began printing documents at
work and bringing them home to upload
there's nothing on this property to
suggest the scale of the Scandal perhaps
the gamer's chair as a nod to the gaming
platform he used to share National
Secrets he won't be needing it for a
while
because at a Boston court hearing
attended by his family Tashira learned
the charges against him
he was brought into court in handcuffs
wearing a beige prison suit
the 21 year old is accused of retaining
classified documents and transmitting
National Defense information
he had been arrested the day before by
the FBI
it emerged in his criminal charges that
he called himself Jack online and
revealed he was in the U.S Air National
Guard he was granted a top secret
security clearance in 2021 that was
required for his job as a computer
network technician
this is one example of the documents
that Tashira uploaded which we've
partially blurred it refers to the war
in Ukraine from nearly two months ago
the box that can be read in this image
appears to show the extent of Western's
Special Forces on the ground in Ukraine
including apparently 50 from the UK
much of the information was designed to
brief military bosses at the U.S
pentagon their boss addressed the leak
as he boarded Air Force One to fly home
from Ireland I've instructed the
department to make sure that they get to
the root of why he had access in the
first place number one and number two to
focus extensively on the extent to which
it all occurred and that's going on
right now I have nothing to report
Beyond what's already been reported a
digger now blocks the route towards
tashira's home it was up this road that
the FBI followed his digital Footprints
ultimately they used human sources to
identify him chat room contacts who
matched his vehicle registry photo to
images online of the man they knew as
Jack
he now remains in custody as the
criminal process kicks in in North Titan
Tashira is remembered as reclusive he
was a quiet kid and he had a lot of
online friends more than he did real
life friends and he just kind of kept to
himself he is the young Airman who
shared National secrets on a gaming site
for him the game is up
James Matthews Sky News in North Dighton
Massachusetts